o
boa tarde a todos a todos muito obrigado
pelo convite
eu sou natural de picos do piauí entra a
brasília de pau de arara
cheguei 1967 na cidade satélite de
sobradinho é comecei melhores condições
de vida vem para brasília bc a vender
jornal é 1983 disputei com currículo
melhor jornal de brasília e o jornal
chama diário de brasília jornal extinto
e foi a partir da venda de jornais que
eu comecei a descobrir leitura como o
convite foi feito à minha pessoa com uma
leitura mudou a minha vida e as
primeiras descobertas da leitura foi
pela obra ea atualidade de trabalhar e
de jornal e chegaram quatro da manhã da
rádio jornal espera o jornal chegar o
diário de brasília e e olha a capa do
jornal
os conteúdos porque não tinha leitura é
obrigação nem a a matéria e tinha lá a
notícia meu gol de pelé no contra o
vasco da gama em 1969 no rio de janeiro
aí já com essa percepção ea demanda
leitor passava no comércio seu lado no
exemplo um senhor
eu já cheguei a falar com o com essa
idéia esse pensamento de que passar essa
informação olha aqui tem uma notícia o
futebol
aí já o o outro tinha condições de ler o
jornal interno o conteúdo ainda essa
informação pra ele ficar muito feliz
porque era uma descoberta da leitura é a
demanda de da informação das pessoas
em 1975 eu o destino da minha vida e
pela universidade de brasília convidado
para vir trabalhar pra dona chica a
saudosa dona chip mesmo e memória
faleceu mas foi a pessoa que me deu
condições de de trabalhar em jornal em
nova descoberta porque eu cheguei
trabalhava na banca de revista que ela
lhe o melhor que o nacional também
perdendo só um pouco
é ela no havaí onde tem um múltiplo uso
que era a pequena margem do jornal
e quando eu cheguei aqui na universidade
já era outro público outro outras
leitura e aí eu comecei a vender o folha
de são paulo estado de são paulo jornal
do brasil o globo e os jornais de
esquerda que eu não sabia o significado
ideológico quero jornal movimento é é a
jornal pasquim e aí fui descobrir essas
leituras é óbvio a tarde do trabalho em
1982 eu fui passear na cidade de goiás e
conhecia a dona cora coralina e foi pra
mim é uma mudança de de importância de
pegar um autógrafo de conhecer a pessoa
pessoalmente cheguei lá aconteceu com
ela e perguntei pra dona coralina qual a
influência da leitura da flora ó antónio
pode ver e guimarães rosa e essa
pergunta que hoje estreia flores e pode
ir lá na biblioteca só em olhar os
livros e eu me lembro até hoje que eu
disse que se até hoje que é já ali na
época isso no interior de goiás
já a linha obra se falou fernando pessoa
mário de sá carneiro foi uma coisa muito
importante conhecer a pessoa à vida e à
obra e eu queria falar um pouco dos
fundadores da universidade de brasília
por que eu tenho que agradecer o doutor
darcy ribeiro que foi fundadora da
cidade não estaria falando aqui sobre se
não fosse o doutor darcy ribeiro
anísio teixeira rebateu da rocha oswaldo
trigueiro abrigou renô é vitor nuno leal
lúcio costa oscar niemayer e essas
pessoas todas que foram os fundadores
foi uma das pessoas mais importantes da
universidade e com o passar do tempo eu
fui inibe a nagem de livro seminários
aqui na universidade to o prazer de
conhecer vários autores como eles
olhando sua zona e pra mim falou a uma
bênção divina que é conhecido este autor
não se explica é teu tov do saramago o
passar do tempo a minha vida foi mudando
pelas descobertas acidentalidade de
conhecer os autores de deter a
proximidade com ele ea contextualização
porque chegava pediu o top é muito fácil
agora você chegar no autor e falar não
sou chico mas que isto coreolando lança
nessa cidade
aí eu descobri essa intuição essa
sensibilidade de quando chega ao autor
que está contextualizada e foi
descoberta fantástica porque a eu
conheci no último momento maravilhoso de
conhecimento nesse sentido é de gohan
hubble de ligar essas pessoas muito
importante e luto caro pra mim no
sentido de reconhecimento o nosso
explica rg brehn são pensadores
nacionais internacional
com o passar do tempo eu fui me
especializando ela a parte mais serviços
humanos e quando o exemplo quando a sua
zona de novo o do livro aqui
eu fui convidado para falar com ele mas
quando cheguei no hotel nacional
ele já tinha eu fui use óleo encontrar
com ele
quando eu cheguei lá elas 96 aí a pessoa
falou olha chico é ele já antecipou a
viagem e voltou pra tela boca frisch que
tristeza mas ao mesmo tempo eu vou
chegar lá quem estava chegando no balcão
do internacional era minha conta eu
falei nossa mike que maravilha que
acidentalidade que eu fiquei muito feliz
já fui falar com ele e ele lançou o
livro de brasília e gostaria de pegar um
automóvel que eu fui correr lá lá lá
está na bienal tem os livros de todos e
eu cheguei lá e prá ele depois ele deu
uma palestra no dia seguinte na bienal
foi na livraria e eu fiquei muito feliz
porque eu vou te dar uma canja e voltou
a gravar o meu livro na a sua felicidade
entendeu essa acidentalidade esses
momentos são é imprescritível e falar
dessas coisas porque eu tenho muita
sorte
os autores o eduardo galeano foi outro
momento também de importância ímpar
cheguei no hotel que estava hospedado a
a produtora internacional rs
internacional da bienal falar olha ele
não vai te receber
puxa vida leva lá por favor
aí quando eu cheguei ele estava saindo
assim a boa noite e boa noite brasil e
estou aqui conversando pela do ribeiro
diria seu teodoro e quando eu falei do
seu teodoro e e aí do darcy ribeiro o o
o domingo da folha nos olhando do dólar
mudou pra mim foi muito importante esse
momento porque a idéia de culpa
histórias da o autor ea obra e eu fui
conversando com ele e me deu ao top eu
eu falei olha é é um transfer ivo essa
questão do documentário idade com os
autores
para fechar essa coisa eu agradeço muito
o convite do ted
e por falar eu tomei um nervoso porque é
edno não falo para tanto público eu
gosto de atender essas pessoas na
livraria espontaneamente
muito obrigado por tudo bota o